can you finish off the sentence my
greatest challenge is
oh man um
that's a big question that's a really
big question
i'm sorry to interrupt but i just want
to let you guys know that
this episode is a partnership with pbs
i'm working with them on a really cool
project called american portrait i'm
going to give you more details on what
it's about at the end of this episode so
please stick around for that
but a quick little rundown basically
american portrait is a national
storytelling project and a way for you
to get involved by submitting your
answers to questions and prompts
like the one in this episode on their
website pbs.org
american portrait let's get back to the
episode for now but please stick around
till the end
to hear more about how you can get
involved in the project i'm working on
with pbs my greatest challenge is to be
happy with what life has given me
versus my expectations of what
i wished my life could be um
i'm 41. and it's funny that you
i'm sorry if i'm breaking up i just
found out a friend of mine died today
i'm 41 and i'm not a mother
i don't have a family i live on my own
i love my mom and dad and my brothers um
but at this age in my life i thought i
would have had a great career
and family and children and the white
pick of fence and the two dogs
but it didn't happen and that's okay
my biggest challenge is
seeing myself as an adult and not as a
child
if that makes any sense i don't know if
that does it absolutely it does
absolutely yeah in every way yeah okay
cool your friends agree
so i i have a child i have a
four-year-old
and i sometimes a lot of times feel like
i'm a kid raising a kid because it was
like
not something that i that was planned
and so i like kind of got thrown into it
sooner than i felt like i would have
been ready for it so that's like
it's like an everyday thing i feel like
i'm totally ill-equipped to be raising
another human being
i think my greatest challenge is staying
out of my own way
and letting my mind kind of block me off
to opportunities that
were always there but i maybe never saw
him because of
my own character defects in my adult
life i've tried changing locations and
just like running from place to place
and i feel like it kind of set me behind
because i thought that i was running for
something and maybe i was running away
from something that i couldn't get away
from
what do you think you're running away
from
um i don't know that could get pretty
personal
my greatest challenge is removing my
ego from situations that are bigger than
me seeing
outside of everything reasoning
with people instead of just losing my
temper right away
an example would just be the year 2020.
that's it my greatest challenge is
overcoming my ego
that's so interesting you said that
because the girl before you said the
same thing no way
yeah that's crazy okay i can change my
ass no no no i do
i would like if you went into details as
to why that's your answer
well you see ego goes both ways right
ego is
how either how highly you view yourself
but it also affects how lowly you view
yourself and right now i'm kind of in
that place where i
look at myself very lowly and it's you
know it's
affecting my ego very negatively my
greatest challenge
is
understanding what can't be understood
kind of like learning what the right
amount of like caring about something is
i either care too much about something i
don't care at all my greatest challenge
is self-confidence
communication trying to change people
finding direction making a decision to
not buy sneakers every month
right now my greatest challenge is uh
probably staying alive i'm an older guy
frankly every week i pick up a newspaper
community newspaper
i recognize somebody that i know that
have passed
you know being older you know you just
you get reminded of it all the time
i took things for granted when i was
younger because i i could
back in those days i was probably
thinking that oh 10 years from now i'm
going to be doing this 10 years down
with doing that
i'm at the stage of my life right now
i'm hoping that i'm still around in 10
years
you know basically it actually really
just being around
being alive being able to do things well
i hope you stay alive for a very long
time i hope so too
my greatest challenge is accepting
criticism my last breakup
i mean i was just criticized for being
too
too caring and too smothering
i guess was the word that was used so
yeah that was difficult to take in
because
you want to care for the people that you
love i feel like my
biggest challenge in life is uh living
up to my parents expectations
uh mostly my father's though what did he
expect from you
i think he really wants to be able to
brag about his children
um and i've always felt like i've never
had anything that he could brag about
about me my greatest challenge is
just being a woman in the stem field i'm
a nuclear engineer
and i'm one of the only people
that's a female and muslim at my work i
graduated college at 20
so like navigating the workforce as
pretty much still a teenager is kind of
difficult when
having to deal with professionals as a
as a male
like as a man you know people don't
really like talk about um emotions and
stuff like that as men
you see all these other things how men
are supposed to be it just it kind of
bothers you growing up
you know especially i'm short all kinds
of stuff goes on with me you know
in your own head but just getting past
those little like negative things and
stuff
trying to be as positive positive and
like happy as i can be
that's something i'm always working on
it still it still gets me to some days
but i think that's something that i just
want to make sure
i i can handle so i can teach and get
other people to
know that they are loved and stuff
depression sucks
the feeling of waking up in the morning
and immediately wanting to go back to
bed
is probably the
most annoying feeling because there's
nothing you can really do about it
and it's just there no matter how hard
you try to
i guess get up and be happy
parents like they're
everything
and like they're nothing
how are they everything and how are they
nothing
um
this is getting deep i guess everything
because
like they're all i knew growing up and
stuff
and then also nothing because of how
it's changed
like how i've changed mental illness and
the stigma behind it
can you explain more um i think that
it's really normalized and
it's not become like romanticized but
it's become something that people
i don't think take as seriously for
example like i have ocd
disordered ocd disorder i have ocd
and um you'll hear like everybody and
their mother say like they have ocd in a
day like a million people say that
and it's like something that has like
changed my life
and like affects my quality of life so
it's like hard
to like see that and hear that when
like people don't have any idea and
or like i also um have
um they're so embarrassing
let me just like collect it my thoughts
and another
like example for me i also have bipolar
disorder
and that is something that um
a lot of people like joke about or
and it's not even like that it bothers
me that they joke about it like it's
never bothered me before
but i think that it just like has
changed my life
in like such a way that like i'll never
be the same
and so hearing people like
change their mind once and go oh my god
i'm so bipolar
is really annoying um
but i like him just seeing him for the
first time since like elementary school
and i'm like yeah so
let me tell you i've been since
elementary school
like i don't tell anybody this stuff she
didn't even know any of this stuff and
she's been my best friend
like my childhood best friend forever so
how do you feel now
would you feel hopeful
some days
yeah some days what help
um the people i love probably
above all like i'd be nothing without
them
i could not live like a second on the
services
is she one of them yes i love you
we just got a tattoo together no way
i'm like the et is my initials and okay
is hers so we like put them in there
wait what does it say
so why'd you guys choose that um
i just think we like went through a lot
of the same things when we were growing
up
and we both kind of sheltered each other
we always had
like as happiness growing up like no
matter what
and you guys have been friends since
when kindergarten
how do you guys want to end this episode
i have a good one just give me like
10 seconds um
i see you are important say that again
everybody stop looking at me i'm being
soft right now
you are important okay and so are you
thank you thank you thank you guys for
making it to the end of the episode
i'm gonna explain more about the project
i'm working on with pbs
if you want to get involved please keep
listening the more people that get
involved the better it's gonna turn out
like i said earlier the project i'm
working on with pbs is called american
portrait which is a national
storytelling project
exploring what it means to be american
today the first portion
is focused on the stories of everyday
americans and the second part is a
documentary series on pbs
this documentary will be made of stories
that you'll submit on pbs.org
american portrait here are the exact
steps you'll need to take
to submit your story go to pbs.org
american portrait
i'll have it linked in my description
once you get on the website you'll see a
variety of prompts and questions for you
to answer
for example the question that you just
saw in today's episode is on there right
now
and it's really easy for you to get as
creative as you want with your
submission
because they allow you to submit your
answer as a photo video
or a text once you submit your answer
it'll go up on their website
and like i said before the more people
that do this the better the project and
the documentary will turn out
so it'd be cool if you also shared your
answer on your social media
or if you have family and friends that
you think would like to get involved
make sure to share it with them as well
that's pretty much it again please make
sure to check it out
pbs.org american portrait linked in my
description
thank you guys for watching i love you
all and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you